scientific studies do indeed seem to
indicate that being in nature has very
positive effects on humans both mentally
and physically one Theory suggests that
there are certain compounds given out by
plants that have a calming and
therapeutic effect on humans the
compound fights on side is given off by
many plants in order to keep insects
away but may in fact instead have very
positive and stress reducing effects on
us
humans other theories try to connect it
to psychology that nature induces a
certain state of attention in humans
that is less demanding on the brain than
its activity others still also connected
to biology and evolution the American
biologist Edward O Wilson coined the
term biophilia to describe a hypothesis
that humans have an innate drive to be
attracted to when seek connection with
other creatures and natural environments
we have evolved to be in need of certain
things